today's lesson was crazy huh not that
crazy
tori nichols may not be who she appears
but her deep connection to the karate
kid legacy
could be revealed in season 3. hints
point toward tori having a complicated
past
and it might include ally mills cobra
kai is part of a generational saga
after all and tori's real backstory
might have a huge impact
here's everything we know so far as well
as all the theories about tori's
mysterious history
can you actually fight
when tory nichols first shows up in
season 2 we're immediately struck by her
natural fighting abilities
look are you sure that you want to do
though she's a little messy compared to
cobra kai's more technically trained
students
you can't deny that tori shows some
incredible speed aggression
and fearlessness in a fight it's like
it's what she was meant to do
which makes sense if the theories about
her character are true
i think it means exactly what it sounds
like she might have come out of nowhere
as a new cobra kai fighter
but tori likely has deep connections to
the legacy of the karate kid
and those connections might be through
ali mills
when ali's name popped up on johnny's
phone at the end of season two
we were already speculating that the
iconic character could make her return
to the karate kid universe
are you okay just leave me alone but
ally's comeback
might not just be about reuniting with
johnny or daniel it's possible that it's
a huge hint at tori's backstory
the most obvious clue that tori is ally
mill's daughter
comes from the way she introduces
herself after fighting miguel
tori says her name is tori with a y
this is a reference to the moment when
ali officially introduces herself to
daniel in the karate kid
you got a name ally with an eye one
thing's for sure it definitely draws an
instantaneous connection between tori
and ali
since the karate kid is set 35 years
before cobra kai
and ali mills is the ex of both daniel
and johnny
bringing tori into season 2 and bringing
ally into season 3
could be a clever setup to introduce a
major plot bombshell
but of course there's one wrench in this
theory tori mentions her mother
and she doesn't sound like ally at all
however tori being ali's secret daughter
is
exactly the kind of plot twist the
showrunners might have up their sleeves
tori tells miguel that she has a brother
and an unnamed mother
who worked as a waitress but was fired
for stealing expired food to feed her
children
this definitely doesn't sound like ally
and to make matters even more
complicated
tori's past has made her hate all rich
people that's why she despises
princesses like samantha who were lucky
enough to have
rich daddies to foot their bills yeah
well not all of us get to use daddy's
credit card the problem is
ally was one of those rich princesses
that tori hates so much
so if ally really is tori's birth mom it
means tori is actually adopted and ally
gave her up
revealing so clearly that tori despises
rich people could be a small preview of
the kind of feelings that might come out
if or when she realizes that her
waitress
mother might not be her biological
mother and that her biological mother is
someone with money who chose to give her
up
given the fact that cobra kai has turned
the karate kid into a generational saga
with daniel training both his daughter
sam and johnny's son robbie
it makes sense that tori isn't just a
random character but part of the karate
kid legacy
the fact that tori hates sam also
reflects johnny and daniel's
relationship
you can think of tori as johnny and sam
as daniel if ali really is tori's mother
it would also put ali right in the
middle of their everlasting rivalry
and complicate tori's relationship with
both of them basically it would be the
perfect way to introduce ally and a
bunch of drama
and to dig deeper into tori's character
and fighting abilities
there are a few things we notice about
tori right away in the season 3 trailer
that hint at what we can expect when the
show returns
first we see that she changed her hair
color she could be trying to turn a new
leaf after the disastrous season 2
ending
or maybe she's trying to hide from
someone there's also footage of her in
what seems to be
an underground fight club it's possible
that she gets some life-changing news
and decides to be even more rebellious
than usual
that sounds like a challenge i like a
challenge
it looks like sam is there as well which
could point to a fight
or perhaps an eventual understanding
between the two rivals
sam is still training and trying to get
over how guilty she feels about what
robbie did to miguel robbie what did you
do
but what does that say about our future
with tori we see the two confronting
each other in the trailer
with no fist drawn yet so is it possible
that sam and tori could make amends
we'd love to see those two tough chicks
fighting on the same side
if you recall the ending of season two
the all-out brawl was started by tori
trying to get revenge on sam for kissing
miguel
you kissed miguel but it resulted in
miguel being critically injured
this leads to a few questions like will
tori and miguel's relationship recover
does she blame herself for his injury
it's hard to say
since we don't see them having a big
heart to heart or even a fight in the
trailer
if tori does find out that ally is her
mother it could be what brings her and
miguel close together
you're having fun right yes i am having
fun there are still many questions but
we want to know what you think
could ally be tori's mother is there a
future for her and miguel
or room for friendship with sam let us
know in the comments don't forget to hit
that like button and subscribe to our
channel for more
thanks for watching